Don't move!
You knew it was me.
Liaison is a very
exciting spy thriller
mixed with an
impossible love story.
The backbone of
the whole series
is the romance between
Eva Green's character
and my character.
It's set against a
background of espionage
based on real cybersecurity
problems that
can happen and has happened.
At the beginning of the story,
the whole country is under
a massive cyberattack.
So, it's quite scary.
They can bring this
entire city to its knees.
And there's nothing
we can do to stop them.
Alison lives with Albert.
I've been seeing someone
for the past five years,
and we're going to get married.
At the start of the story,
we see them in love, passionate.
Until Gabriel,
Alison's ex-lover,
he resurfaces in Alison's
life unexpectedly.
And then her whole world
is turned upside down.
Why didn't you ever
tell me about him?
Because I'm not a good person.
She discovers that he's kind of
connected to the cyberattacks.
So, it's very conflicted.
I'm trying to forget
everything and move on.
And you're not a
happy memory.
Vincent Cassel and Eva Green
were really strong reasons
that I wanted to get
involved in this.
Action!
Both actors bring a lot of
power and eroticism
and intelligence to
everything they do.
Being on set with her,
I have to say that
is really easy
because she has
great sense of humor.
He's full of energy,
he's very free,
and crazy in a wonderful way.
Okay, picture up. Here we go.
There's a huge
amount of suspense.
There's a whodunit
of a story to uncover.
There's a lot of action
sequences in it.
It's extremely ambitious.
We haven't seen this on
television before.
Pull up.
Liaison is very intense,
very dramatic.
Gritty, fast-paced.
It's exciting.
And it makes you feel like "uh"
when you watch it.
So, it's amazing.
♪♪
Gabriel!
I should be calling
the cops right now.
Mm-hmm, you should.